hello everyone welcome back to PGA chain
design today we kind of look into how to
model this three stone ring and what you
need to pay attention on the structure
are you ready let's get started
[Music]
to start this ring you need to have the
exactly stone size that you are going to
set into the ring and position the angle
that you like first if you like to know
how to build a stone I have a video here
that can show you step-by-step process
you can check out the video I will have
a link in the description below first of
all I would like to set it up my ring
size in this case I'm going to set it a
diameter for 16 millimeters we are going
to pipe our prong later on but I want to
have a guideline here in my case I'm
going to have a prong sizes one point
two millimeter in diameter so I'm going
to offset my circle four point six
millimeter so that way when I'm drawing
any of the line I want to make sure it's
not passing with this circle there okay
so that's starting with the arc I'm
going to have this somewhere over here
we can have a prong a little bit longer
so that will be good for the stone
setting and I want to make sure my near
is on on my all snap so that will snap
over there so that will be my first line
if I'm looking at my review I wanted to
have a line go from roughly the same
height and then it's coming over and
coming to the center roughly something
like this and then this my snapping
somewhere that you don't want it and we
can do project you see plain and we want
to delete the input equal yes so this
one will be flat and let's take a look
on what we have the line that we are
going to create we are going to use the
command call curved front to view and
we're gonna have this curve in this
curve so you're automatically creating
this curve over there so let's do a test
that's piping this curve and see what
happened we're gonna use the pipe and
then the radius is point six over here
and point six on the other end notice
that it's just right at where my ring
size is it's not past that ring size
that is what that reference line for
okay so this is the first that I have
you want to check if it is too close to
the stone like the one that I have on
the left but not touching the stone like
the one I have on the right okay so if
that is the case instead of a do it like
again and changing all the time what we
can do is we can rebuild this guy to be
less control point all right and then we
want to pipe it one more time this time
we want to record the history and we
pipe it over there so if that is too
close now we can turn on our we can
select our curve and we can turn on the
control point and we can move it around
so it is not too close to the stone so
that way allow you to do some editing
and for example if this is not close
enough we can have a movie in I always
like to have my prong at exactly weird
45-degree angle it will look much nicer
so you can to get into the way that you
like I might need to have this point
going down because it's touching a stone
it doesn't look too good on the side
view so you will spend some time to
tweak it until you find the best curve
for the stone there then let's do a test
to mirror on the other side and see how
it goes so the first one will look
something like this and I'm going to
temporary to hide those two the second
one that we are going to do it's gonna
go from here and the game we want to go
a little bit higher and we're gonna come
over here and make it into something
like this and blend it to the inside for
inking and again you can adjust to
whatever that looks good to you all
right
so after that we are going to looking at
our review again on my right view I'm
going to draw
not a curve this curve is going to go
from there and end this somewhere here
so this will be the curve that I'm going
to use for the smaller storm
let's use the curved front to view we're
gonna have this curve in this curve so
now we are getting this curve right here
okay in order for you to plan really
well
I'm actually need to have the somewhere
planned from this point to this point
so we're gonna use the split command we
want to split with the point somewhere
about here and this one somewhere with
the point somewhere about here so let's
did it this one and did it about it so
now we have that opening over there we
can use the blend tool to blend the
curve from here to here alright so that
looks alright to me I'm going to select
all of them join them and also rebuild
into ten point all right let's do a test
with the pipe the same time eated I'm
going to have and see if that go well
now that's turned on what we had before
and see if that is a good match there
all right it looks nice over there then
I'm going to have this one and mirror to
the other side all right so let's double
check and see if everything is all right
and again this might be too long you
might want it to be shorter longer
whatsoever I'm not gonna spend time and
tweaking it for the demonstration
purpose here I would like to show you
what to do next
so we are going to go mirror to the
other side and then we will have the
setting part is almost done
okay now the second part that I need to
do is about reaching we're going to have
this shank we're going to have a shank
it's going to start it somewhere a
little bit inside of my prong and it's
coming over here and coming over here
okay
so again if that doesn't look too good
to you you can always adjust it alright
so that is that and I'm going to
creating a area that we can set the
stone later so let's go ahead to
creating the profile for the profile I
always like to use the conic corner and
because it will give me a very nice
cushion looking because he will give me
a really nice cushion looking shape
there and let me move this one from the
midpoint to the quadrant of our inside
of a ring shank and then you can adjust
the thickness if you like too I may also
want to make it a little bit thicker
there okay so now I have a cross-section
over there I'm going to mirror to the
other side and let's use the sweet one
this is our rail this is going to be
cross section and cross section I always
like to have my seam inside of a ring
shank alright so then we have the pollen
ring shank if you want to have about a
little bit in there you can create
another profile there on the bottom now
let's take a look right here right at
the front view we have this over there
I'm gonna make a copy and want to rotate
it into the angle is 90 degree with the
rail that is going to and then we're
gonna take a look on this view I want to
make sure it's touching the prong I also
want to make sure it's a little bit thin
there alright so that's starting with
sweep one rail and make sure you turn on
a history this is the rail this is the
cross section and we always want to make
sure the seam is inside of a ring shank
okay so let's take a look on this one if
that doesn't look good to you we're
going to pick up the curve and then we
can move those points in and out up and
down to get the best curve to fitting
into a design alright so you can go
ahead and tweak it until you like it so
once you like
everything's let's go ahead to cap it
and of course we want to have a rather
ages so we will go ahead to feather the
edges say point three millimeter if you
like it it's go ahead to mirror to the
other side if that inside doesn't look
nice to you you can go ahead to using a
sweep instead of piping alright so
there's a lot of things that you can
tweak over there now let's talk about
the structure I'm going to turn the
stone off and let's take a look on that
alright so those are nice they are
touching so that will be fine on the
casting those two is touching with this
red one so they are fine with the
structure however am I facing the issue
is if something is heating on this
direction in my crash to the other prong
so we do actually need some structure in
the middle to hold it okay so this is
what I will do I will go to the top view
and I'm going to use the arc starting
with here roughly here and then we want
to get arc there
all right so this is the curve that we
have there that's bringing up to where
the location should be and where's that
location should be it should be under
the girdle area and we can move in a
little bit all right let me turn this
stone off one more time so now we have
this one here we can go ahead to pipe it
again the pipe we're going to use like
point four millimeter there so this way
it's giving you the structure that is
going to hold on this side so you won't
get crash or the stone will hold it
better so we will just need to mirror to
the other side
and we'll do the same on those two all
right so the propulsion may not look
100% correct yet is because I want to
show you something really quick but you
get the idea and feel free to let me
know how you're doing if you want to
know more about a stone setting don't
forget to check out my course on my
website for the stone setting so when
they finish is you have a nice
proportion and the right prong size and
something similar like this I hope you
enjoy please like and share and comment
on my video that helped me to reach more
people that want to learn right now
thank you and I'll see you next
[Music]